die ebola epidemie im kongo will einfach
nicht enden obwohl die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wer hier
viel früher als bei der verheerenden
epidemie 2014/15 in westafrika reagiert
hat bekommt der kongo den ebola ausbruch
einfach nicht in den griff
anfang des jahres wurde sogar ein
verdachtsfall in schweden gemeldet
droht jetzt eine weltweite epidemie
pixum science fiction nur hier gibt es
tag die spannende wissenschafts videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
die gefahr war nicht übertrieben der
patient in schweden kamen gerade aus
burundi das an den kongo grenzt er
spuckte blut und hatte auch blutigen
stuhl die notaufnahme in der
schwedischen stadt n köpping wurde
geschlossen das personal überwacht weil
das risiko ganz real war ein ebola
ausbruch in europa schon beim ausbruch
in westafrika kamen die ersten
infizierten nach europa es war ein
großes glück dass hier nichts
schlimmeres passiert ist wie hier bei
pixum hatten als einziges medium den
ausbruch damals regelmäßig verfolgt auch
als das interesse der medien st sind wir
damals dran geblieben wie auch jetzt
ebola ist ein fieber das in rund der
hälfte der fälle zum tod führt es
beginnt relativ harmlos mit einer grippe
aber im weiteren verlauf fangen die
opfer überall an zu bluten und sterben
schließlich an multiplen organversagen
übertragen wird die krankheit meistens
von sogenannten reservoir würden das
sind wildtiere die gejagt und gegessen
werden durch die abholzung von wäldern
rücken menschen immer näher an diese
populationen heran und jagen dann
flughunde affen oder zum beispiel
stachelschweine dieses buschfleisch
führt dann meistens zum ausbruch der
seuche in schweden hat sich der patient
jetzt als nicht mit ebola infiziert
herausgestellt aber genau ein solches
szenario ist das horrorszenario der
epidemiologie ein infizierter patient
reist in eine millionenmetropole ein und
verbreitet dort stundenlang das tödliche
virus und wie schwer ebola dann zu
bekämpfen ist zeigt jetzt der kongo so
wurden hier inzwischen 60.000 menschen
mit einem experimentellen impfstoff
geimpft die weltgesundheitsorganisation
vero war damit im gegensatz zum ausbruch
2014 dieses mal deutlich schneller in
aktion getreten
generaldirektor täters
es war sofort vor ort und organisierte
den start der impfkampagne mit trotzdem
ist die zahl der toten jetzt auf über
400 gestiegen
insgesamt sind in der umgebung der
großstadt wenn ihr jetzt 658 menschen
erkrankt und die gegend ist politisch
instabil
bei blutigen protesten vor der
präsidentenwahl wurde jetzt anfangen
januar ein krankenhaus angegriffen die
impfungen mussten ausgesetzt werden
zudem ist die umgebung dort heiß
umkämpft milizen kämpfen dort um den
zugang zu rohstoffen und damit um viel
geld eine schwierige situation bei der
eindämmung einer solchen krise zudem
kommt dass die neuen fälle zunehmend in
städten und dem umland auftreten was die
bekämpfung zusätzlich erschwert die whu
ist jetzt besorgt dass die bekämpfung
des gefährlichen fiebers so kaum noch
möglich ist und sich die solche weiter
ausbreitet wir halten euch auf jeden
fall auf dem laufenden
hier geht es weiter mit unbedingt
draufklicken dem wissenschafts rewind
2018 bei doktor watson
da bin ich neben vielen anderen auch
dabei richtig cool geworden und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran